a recent wb job posting appears to
indicate hogwarts legacy
could be a live service game and the
internet
is freaking out i'll get you caught up
on the news why i
actually think it could be a good thing
and what even is
a live service game all that and more in
today's hogwarts legacy video
people of the internet retroaction tour
here if we're meeting for the first time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and a few like me are looking
forward to hogwarts legacy
then be sure and give this video a like
before you go it helps me know you guys
are enjoying the hogwarts legacy content
and want to see
even more of it today's video is broken
down into four different sections we'll
start by talking about wb's focus
on live service games and why hogwarts
legacy could be a part of that push
how we should define live service games
what the concerns would be for hogwarts
legacy
and then finally i'll give you a few
ideas i have for how hogwarts legacy can
be an absolutely phenomenal live service
title
i'll include timestamps for each of
these different sections and you can
also use the chapter markers in the
timeline if you're just interested in a
specific section of the video
to start off why are we even talking
about hogwarts legacy as a live service
game
well back in late january there was a
job posting on wb's career site for a
virtual
games production mba intern for the
summer of 2021
and at the time of recording this video
the ad actually is still available
online so if you do want to read it for
yourself you can do that at this time
i'll post a link down in the description
of course i'll also include screenshots
here in the video to any important
sections that we need to discuss
to be honest with you guys there's a lot
here in this job posting for us to break
down
here's the first bit that stands out to
me the wbie which stands for warner
brothers interactive entertainment
production summer intern will have the
opportunity to learn about the way a
game publisher
evaluates new game opportunities
remember that by working closely with
the executive producer
wbie is currently involved in a variety
of new projects ranging from casual
games to core games featuring our
well-known franchises on all platforms
console digital mobile with a heavy
focus
on live service so there you go
that is what tipped a lot of folks off
and has everyone asking
hey does this apply to hogwarts legacy
and if so what does that mean
for the story this was supposed to be a
single player story game
what's going on here now if you just
looked at that alone you might think
well hey hogwarts legacy is delayed
until 2022
it's probably not included in this
considering this position is for an
internship during the summer of 2021
well let's keep reading from the listing
so we can see a little more about what
this intern will be doing
so some of the tasks for the inter will
include drive competitive research
tear downs genre analysis and benchmarks
of
external games and market trends to
support project green lights and
translate best practices into
actionable product strategies and then
it goes on to say participate in initial
developer diligence meetings
assistance and setting up demos on a
variety of different hardware
playthroughs of various game demos
write-ups on game demos both from a
gameplay
and market opportunity perspective so it
seems
pretty clear to me that this job is
going to be heavily focused on
gathering information and conducting
research on what maybe
other companies are doing and even
helping setting up demos
so to me all of this speaks to planning
something that is not
ready for release right now but how can
we maybe add live service elements
to what we've got so what other games
could wb possibly be talking about here
we know they mentioned quote well-known
franchises and if you look at the titles
they're releasing this year i would say
two of them fall into that category
there's lego star wars the skywalker
saga back for blood and gotham knights
now back for blood looks promising but
it would be a stretch to call it a
well-known franchise since it's brand
new both star wars and gotham knights
though
absolutely they certainly fit the bill
that being said when it comes to live
service the lego star wars games are
well known quantities at this point they
have a tried and true formula that works
so it would be pretty strange to me if
we saw them add some sort of live
service component
there with a lego game it's possible but
it would just surprise me
of those three that i just mentioned i
think gotham knights is clearly the most
likely title to receive strong support
after launch with live service elements
but would this job posting really only
focus
on one live service title the listing
clearly indicates more than just
one so in that case i think we have to
look at hogwarts legacy as well as the
2022 suicide squad game as other
potential candidates
now it's entirely possible hogwarts
legacy isn't part of the live service
push at all but with it already getting
a lengthy delay to 2022 and wb seemingly
placing a focus on live service
i think it's safe to say that it will
indeed happen
and i actually think it could be a good
thing of course i always want to hear
from you guys and today i'd love to know
if there are any games you play
regularly that you would consider to be
a live service game let me know down in
the comments
i also think it's helpful if we can try
to define what wb considers to be a
live service game this isn't a brand new
term but i do feel like it's one we're
seeing more of
lately and there's still a lot of
confusion as to what people actually
mean when they're saying
live service i will say that for me
personally whenever i think of live
service i think of something like
destiny world of warcraft or even
fortnite these are titles that
consistently release new content
and regular updates to their game it
just so happens that all three are also
heavily focused on multiplayer with
various cooperative and competitive
elements
in fact in my mind i've always thought
of live service games as being titles
that focus primarily on multiplayer
but that doesn't always have to be the
case there actually is a wikipedia entry
for
games as a service and here's how they
define it there
in the video game industry games as a
service represents providing video games
or game content on a continuing
revenue model similar to software as a
service
games as a service are ways to monetize
video games either after their initial
sale
or to support a free to play model games
released under the games as a service
model typically receive a long or
indefinite stream of monetized new
content over time to encourage players
to continue paying to support the game
so nothing specifically about
multiplayer there but the focus is
instead on an
indefinite stream of monetized new
content
i would personally even make the
argument that the new content doesn't
always have to be monetized
you can look at something like animal
crossing new horizons which has provided
free updates for the entire first year
of the game's release and it remains to
be seen what's going to happen after
that first year
they might start doing paid dlc they
could continue to do free updates we
just don't know yet
now overall that definition may sound
fine but we as gamers have been burned
too many times by title sporting this
model
take this reddit post for example which
defines live service games as being the
quote promise of a barely functional
game being sold as a
aaa masterpiece that aims to nickel and
dime users for several years
so there are absolutely concerns when it
comes to this model
i posted a poll here on youtube for you
guys asking can hogwarts legacy work
as a live service game 30 percent of you
said yes there's potential
54 said maybe but i prefer not and only
outright said no now i know most of us
are looking forward to the story of
hogwarts legacy and exploring the world
perhaps more than just about anything
else in the game
which means there are fears that parts
of the game could be intentionally held
back
for future dlc or we may see micro
transactions for highly sought after
items the biggest fear by far as i've
seen so many times in the comments on
the videos here is that the game
releases
in a poor or even outright broken state
i'm not going to compare to that game
releasing games as live service can
sometimes trap developers into a
never-ending cycle of trying to fix
a broken game to catch up with the fan
expectations or even giving publishers
the green light to release a broken game
because in the back of their minds and
oh hey this is going to sell well on
name recognition alone
we can just follow it up with the
promise of better things in the future
one of my most played titles ever is the
original destiny which released in a
state that many found frustrating and
even
unacceptable i'm looking at you purple
engrams decrypting into blues
to bungie's credit they would eventually
turn destiny into an incredibly fun
title with a passionate
passionate fan base and yet now they
find themselves on shaky ground once
again
with destiny 2. so we know their
concerns but how does hogwarts legacy
avoid those and deliver an incredible
game that can still
work as live service and keep the fans
not only
tolerant of it but happy and excited
about the live service options
for one they should focus on fulfilling
their initial promise to fans and that
was to make a
story driven action rpg set in the
wizarding world
this has got to be at the forefront guys
this needs to be number one if anyone
from avalanche hears this
you guys have to keep that at the top of
the priority list
now when it comes to the live service
component guys the reason that i am
excited and actually a little bit
optimistic
about this is that this means hogwarts
legacy could potentially be a game
that lives on for months and even years
if it's properly supported
alright so stick with me guys imagine a
post-launch dlc that saw our character
journey
to other wizarding schools or doing a
summer internship at the ministry
of magic seriously like that one has me
so excited could you imagine if you
finish up your first year or whatever
fifth year whenever we're starting at
hogwarts and then maybe you meet a
contact along the story journey where
they work at the ministry you want to
train to be an r and you get to go on
all sorts of these adventures
from the ministry of magic as your kind
of hub yes
sign me up i will pay for that dlc make
it happen
avalanche personally i'm expecting the
main hogwarts legacy game to take place
over the span of one school year but how
great would it be if we got to go on new
adventures and quest with them
throughout
the summer maybe we travel the world
with one of our favorite professors over
the summer to study magical creatures
from other countries or go hunting for
obscure magical artifacts
maybe all of the above one other area of
the wizarding world that seems like it's
just
made for live service would have to be
quidditch
it's something so many fans have asked
for and i think it would work
very well with a live service model
imagine all the different broom
customization options and different
equipment you could have on your player
there could be time trials seasons and
all sorts of different challenges built
around quidditch
personally i like the idea of the added
content sticking with our character from
the main game but
if they wanted to branch out even
further they could always do a dlc
around the triwizard tournament it's an
event in wizarding world history that is
perfect for a video game
unfortunately the timeline just doesn't
match up with the late 1800s of the
hogwarts legacy story
look i'm gonna be honest with you guys i
could go on and on with ideas for how
hogwarts legacy could absolutely
nail the live service experience but now
i'm gonna turn it over
to you guys let me know in the comments
what you'd like to see and if you're new
here be sure and check out our full
hogwarts legacy playlist on the right
side of your screen
as always thank you guys so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon